so it's not about teaching them anything
but it is about
awakening that curiosity you know and
making them passionate
yes and creating that excitement and
that sense of belonging
right of saying like wow how cool is
that
[Music]
miriam tothino thank you for joining me
today how are you good morning thank you
mike
this is exciting thank you for having me
of course
you're in the sunrise all the way from
spain right
yes yes it's about the sun the sun is
going to be rising as we speak today
wonderful amazing so i can't wait to see
the light the light change thank you for
taking this call so early i i really
appreciate it
uh miriam before we talk about you know
enabling children with superhuman tools
to
interact with computers and technology
i'd love to first hear a little about
you because your journey is very
it's very weird it's very non-linear you
know you're from netherlands right now
you're in spain you were
an architect turned into a software
engineer turned
into a book author and passionate about
helping kids
you know interact with really you know
2020 and 2021 and and where
where the world is moving in terms of
technology so i've spoken enough
miriam share with me a little bit about
who you are and and how do you
get sucked into this whole world of
technology
so here's the story uh michael because
today we're gonna be talking about
how technology is now a big part of my
life and the work i do as a writer
but i haven't always been this
passionate about the world of computers
and my dad always wanted me to go into
computer science
and he used to say media miss the future
right
and now we know he was right and that i
completely
missed the point but as a child i
thought that computers were gray
and boring and well instead i went into
college and i studied architecture
and it wasn't until i was 30 years old
that i started to
to get interested in technology and i
taught myself how to code
uh and i discovered that working with
computers could be something fun
full of creativity and that allowed me
to help other people around me
which were the things that drew me in
the first place into architecture and
not into computer science
what is the moment but why you know it's
telling to be an architecture is you
know
a feat on its own right
what prompts you to then say okay you
know what i'm actually going to go and
also teach myself how to code which is
a whole other feat a scary one at that
right
that at the end it's very rewarding but
it is a scary experience for those who
who don't have too many enough guidance
but what prompted you to go there and
what was the experience like
okay so there were two main things that
actually prompted me to to make a switch
the first one was that uh
at the beginning i was very happy being
an architect but then after a while
and we were winning competitions and i
was working in exciting projects and it
was all fun
right during my 20s but at some point
well
the the the studios in which i was
working it was very demanding
so i worked in four different countries
and in every place where i went
uh well there were very long hours no
weekends
it was really really really hard and i
didn't see myself doing that for my
whole life
i said like look this is actually not
working i tried in four different
countries you know
how is this possible like i don't want
to play this game that was
one of the things right and on the other
hand i
at the same time i met my uh husband
now before so boyfriend right and we
started dating
and he's a programmer he's an artificial
intelligence programmer a video games
programmer
and i was already living with him and
the weekend would come and i would say
okay so what are we gonna do right and
he was like look i have this feature in
my engine that i wanna
wow you know like he's really passionate
about this thing
maybe i should try to you're right
because
i think and and here's something that
didn't
i think we don't talk much about when
it's about
to choose a career for us which is like
in order to to be successful as an
architect you need a client
right you need to build things for
someone you know like your designs will
stay in paper if you don't actually get
that client
but what i discovered with coding was
like
if i had an idea you know like of course
you want people to use
your app to use your invention to use
your thing
but there are so many problems in the
world that can actually be solved
through technology that it is a
huge opportunity to actually be doing
something creative that actually help
other people around in an easier way and
more simple way more straightforward you
could say
than being an architect right and that
was something that
um i was not communicated as a child
right right i think that what you're
touching here is is on two
two of the things that excite me most
about about technology which is one
you know it is about taking matters to
your own hands right
the the idea isn't left on the piece of
paper it's not left
as a as an idea for somebody else to go
and implement it really
it really gives life to it in the in an
interactive form you know it doesn't
necessarily is a single as a program you
don't necessarily have to be the one to
to bring it all the way to production
and into millions of people but you can
at least
build something that is much more
meaningful and and showcasing a much
more meaningful way than it is on a
piece of paper but the second piece of
it and what i'm hearing here is that
you're able to take that whole
creativity piece and that whole
artistry side of architecture and bring
that into
you know into the programming life and i
think a lot of people see
programming and technology as you know
very robotic zeros and ones but at the
end
you know every pretty much every
programmer that i talk to talks about it
is a form of art
it's it's really about be being an
artist and you know
no two programmers will you can build
the same program in so many different
ways
and and the way in which you design it
and do it that's an art of its own
yes i think uh it is time that actually
we
reframe the way that we talk about
computer science because if i
talk with my husband as well about this
right like the reason why i went into
architecture is because architecture is
sold to you as an interdisciplinary
career yes
right and i was like okay so i started
design i studied creativity i studied a
structure i studied mathematics i
studied physics you know but i also
studied
drawing and sketching and you know
bringing your ideas to life
right and i thought how is it that we
are
and i think about this a lot right now
you know because i think we are in a
moment in which
architects have the challenge to
actually create our environment
but our environment right now is as
digital as it is in real life
and i think about what if we place
ourselves with the minds of
architects you know to create the
digital future that we want to see right
and have that approach in a more broad
sense and not only you know from from a
computer science and a technical aspect
right i think slowly we are getting
there i want to be optimistic about this
right but i do think that in order to do
that there's
still a long way to go to actually say
look computer science is not
you know a little bit of the science i
don't really like the term right because
it kind of
you know divides you know groups of
people and i think we need
to come up with a better wording as well
to actually
you could say sell it to our children
right or
next time i completely agree and i have
to give a very a very very short
anecdote because i i was recently
speaking to a school
and to a middle school about they told
me that they want to have this
you know this fun week where where kids
study you know
they want to become programmers right
it's just it's a week to to get them to
really sign up for that computer science
class or that programming class and so
the first thing that they tell me is you
know and
and we're going to call it a week of
computer science education
and i was and i heard that i was like
you know if i'm a middle schooler i
don't want to i don't want to go to a
week of computer science education
that's the last thing that i want to do
i want to go to a fun week of problem
solving i want to go
for for the art of of interacting with
screens or or or you know typing
you know whatever it is but but i i
completely agree with you that i think
there's a huge
dissonance right now with between
educators and between
between kids what gets them excited and
i'm saying you know my nieces growing up
very young but the things that get them
excited are things you know if i were to
give them titles the way that educators
give titles to these activities today
i don't think they'd be as excited and
and so i completely agree and mirroring
that that really
you know is a great segue to what you're
working on now in the book that you
wrote
and and the things that you're excited
about which is not just how people are
interacting with with
computers it's specifically how kids are
seeing the evolving world and
what gets them excited about it so so
let's start all the way i know i
wouldn't i wanna
i wanna add to that i normally say uh
michael i normally say that
understanding computers is a superpower
and it is not about
every child becoming a computer
scientist or a
programmer in the future right but it is
like we need to
we need to give them the sense that
knowing how computers work and the
technology around us
you know functions will actually become
an important part of their toolkit
to create their own world in whatever
way they choose
so one day you are painting with brushes
and paintings and the other day
you are customizing liquid templates in
shopify right
like um this is it you know like and
this thing
it's here to stay you know this is not
going away
anytime soon 100 right so it's not about
it's not about whether i don't think you
know we are
anymore in this place where we want our
children to become computer scientists
you know but
as as parents and as educators we need
to we need to teach them about the world
around them
you know it's part of their culture it's
part of their upbringing
i was in that position that i said look
if he if my kid
is young enough to interact with the
screen
he's young enough to know what's going
on behind that
screen and who is responsible for that
you know and who is building that for
him you know
i think as little as three four years
old
we could start having those
conversations so our kids
they don't see technology only as
consumers but they start seeing it
as creators right right
no i i i agree 100 and i think the
motivation for this and
and tell me if i'm if you think i'm
wrong but i think that the motivation
for this is
saying okay now if before people that
were interacting with computers you
would call them computer scientists
these are the people that are
in the forefront of these technologies
but today in order to
just be a successful global citizen you
know
starting in 2020 moving forward you have
to be
you have you have to be comfortable with
these adapting technologies you have to
be relevant
using these technologies and so by
understanding it you're increasing the
likelihood that you'll be able to adapt
and be on the forefront of even just as
a consumer even if you're not going to
be the next engineer right
just as a consumer you have to
understand and be comfortable adapting
and i think that what we're seeing now
with older generations and and the gap
that is continuing to
to to to become greater is this lack of
ad up to
adaptivity and and really not
understanding what's going there
having it being a scary experience and
then not being adaptive to actually
going
and experimenting one of the things that
i always uh tell my grandparents is you
know you can't really ruin anything
right sometimes they're scared of
pressing some buttons as if like
something will break
right like it will shatter but you know
in my mind nothing will shatter the
worst case is you do a restart
but it's a different mindset it's a
different mentality miriam talk to me
about kids talk to me about
communicating technology and screens to
kids and how you
see it needs to be done
for me it was very important uh not to
use the screens from the very beginning
and that's why
when three years ago when i had my baby
i started thinking about
okay and i was a programming teacher
right so when i got my baby i was a
programming teacher i taught hundreds of
students how to switch their careers
into tech right that's what i was doing
and then i got pregnant and i had this
son and i kind of naturally transitioned
into
thinking how am i gonna actually talk
about my kid about
computers and introducing him to this
world and for me it was very important
first that there was no screams
and second that it was really simple i
thought okay how could i bring
some of the elements that i used in my
teaching
and help other people introduce
this topic to their children and start
talking with them at home
that was really the the the key
thing for me when i started this project
i had in mind this vision about
how do i get parents and kids
in bed talking about computers that was
my
right if i can get that you know like my
my work is done here right so i thought
okay you know what we're already reading
books to him
he loves books you know stories are
powerful stories are powerful
and also parents are normally so busy
you know that it's like
i'm i didn't want to give them a book
that they had to prepare
for right and i was like look
today i'm gonna read this book about
farms and animals
tomorrow we read a book about computers
and technology
so this is how there's anona were born
they are a zero and a one
they live inside your computer and uh
they live in the binary world and they
share their adventures right so
it's a book series it comes with a
parent guide at the end that also older
kids are reading and so
but it's like okay how can we actually
make this transition
natural to our children and also
for educators and parents and again it's
not about being educational
right that was also for me the the key
point for the project you know i was
like how educative
i want this to be i think our children
are going to be lifelong learners
we are seeing it right now right so it's
not about teaching them
anything but it is about awakening that
curiosity
you know and making it passionate yes
and creating that excitement
and that sense of belonging right of
saying like
wow how cool is that and now yesterday
for example we were not even reading the
book to him you know like my child of
course he knows a lot about serious
anona and he doesn't much read the book
anymore
but he wants to create his own stories
about what's going on inside the
computer with there's anona and
every night they go to somewhere
different
you know and then say it's like ah and
what happens there daddy what happens
there mommy you know and he's having
this world in his mind it's i think it's
amazing
right like to grab that you know
unbelievable i think that at the end you
know i was very lucky to to grow up in a
place where
my curiosity was you know sparked pretty
early on and
so you know i consider myself a lifelong
learner and i think that at the end
that's really what drives me is that
curiosity and i think that
you know really the differentiator with
a lot of people you know you're seeing
some of the some of the greatest minds
and the greatest innovators at the end
you know it's not necessarily about the
money or it's not about the power it's
about that curiosity you know
i'm thinking why does elon musk have you
know six different ventures each of them
in different domains
that are making such a strong impact uh
you know at the end
he's just a curious person he wants to
learn now he's you know an innovator but
you know you can have also people that
are engineers that are curious you can
have people that are architects that are
curious
or educators that are curious but it's
at the end it's all about that lifelong
learning and that activity
and so i think that's i think that's
fascinating what what techniques
did you find yourself having to use as
you're writing this book for kids
because you're not writing you know a
wikihow that sparks curiosity for teams
you're writing a children's book
about computers and about the internals
of computers so
what is that process like for you
this is a great question like so um
i started um when he was six months old
right and our child didn't sleep much
so the beginnings of the project was
done in a very kind of
sleep deprived situation wow
and i think that was actually a positive
thing for the project because at the end
of the day
i'm talking with a zero and a one right
so if you're really in a very rational
state
um that might not work
right so the very beginning
the very beginning was that well i kind
of
as i said i left my architecture career
some years ago and
after i got my my child he was not
sleeping and
i finally decided like look my work was
to teach coding programming
to 25 people who you know who decided to
quit the careers and
make a switch and um yesterday at 3am in
the morning i was walking around my blog
you know trying to make these babies i
cannot do this
right like i thought like okay i'm just
gonna stay home you know for
you know let's see how this takes you
know but i cannot teach other how to go
to in this
state you know and be responsible for
the future so right i stayed at home and
then i discovered that actually i was
missing
some of that creativity and and quick
thinking and that i experience
as an architect right so i started
journaling a lot
and i started with the artist's way
the the book from julia cameron maybe
you've heard from it
and she gives you two different tools so
she gives you
morning pages which is like you wake up
and you write
three pages like handwritten like
non-stop
just you know bring down the whole thing
and then she also says that once a week
you need to have like an artist date
so i started doing that and um
the first pages were very boring the
first pages were like okay why is my
baby not
sleeping you know like my life is such a
chaos you know i want to go back to
teaching you know where is my life you
know and so on
but then at some point i started okay
you know like and of course you first
need to go through those pages you know
that's what they tell you in the book as
well you know to clear that
stuff up you know and then being a mind
state you know which is like empty and
so you know one day i was talking about
how my creativity was
damaged and and then that same night we
talked with i talked with my husband
about
the whole you know how are we going to
teach him about technology computers and
then one day thursday now we're on the
page and then
ever since they've been there right and
now i don't write three more three pages
but i might write one page in the
morning
and every time that i need to create a
new story and
it comes from that place and here i want
to say something that
i discovered and that many it can
resonate with some people
and i don't think we speak much about
this which is that
the huge role that intuition plays in
all these
right like all the stories for
therosauna they are not coming from
a place of pushing right or
like forcing stuff you know like i first
need to go to a place in which i'm like
very much you know in the side and i let
them
right take the right lead the right
right so uh how do you do that
week i think we don't have time for 20
minutes but
uh
[Music]
i see many people you know being said
like look you know like fat for dreams
you know like
and for me i had to slow down and i
think that's actually the positive
aspect that i had about being a sleep
deprived you know and having that break
in my career
which is like sometimes you need to stop
and slow down
to speed up again right and come from
that
moment of uh i love that
yeah does that answer i think that
a hundred percent and i think that you
know a lot of people are going to come
out of this pandemic myself included and
are going to to to to
to feel much more comfortable with what
the decisions are going to make i think
that
a lot of my friends that i've spoken
with you know everybody's plans have
completely changed
throughout throughout the pandemic and a
lot of people were forced you know
to to slow down a bit and to to go a
little bit more internal and to spend
some meaningful time thinking
whether they like it or not but at the
end i think that a lot of people are
going to come out and and have much more
clarity as to what they want to be doing
and where they want to be
spending their time and i know that i i
also i'm already starting to reflect on
some of these insights that i've gained
throughout
throughout koben miriam i want to thank
you for being so generous with your time
thank you for joining me here
i i wish we had more time to to i have
50 more questions i want to ask you but
for now
the most important question i have left
is three words that you you would use to
describe yourself
i'm passionate about life and work and i
think this is becoming even more
important
in these days in which we are at the
moment
i'm also um an optimistic problem solver
yeah you mentioned before about the
school you know it's not about
you know that problem solver which is
fine you know problem solving week you
know but i think
having a you know designing things with
a positive narrative
an optimistic narrative is becoming more
important
right now also as ever before and
um i think discipline is another one
yes so i'm gonna leave it here there
i love it miriam thank you so so much
and stay safe and stay healthy
i can't wait to first of all read the
books myself second of all
to uh to share these books with with my
nieces and with other kids as well so
thank you for all the work that you're
doing i think it's incredibly important
i think it's one of the most important
things that educators can do and you
know where we are today in preparation
for
a world that nobody knows what it's
going to be like you know in in the
1900s when people used to educate kids
they used to know pretty much
what the kids are going to experience in
their lifetime and what what what
mentality they need to be prepared for
and i think the most exhilarating thing
here is that we don't know what we need
to prepare for we don't know what
adversities are going to strike we don't
know what opportunities are going to
come to us and so i think that what
you're doing here is is extremely
extremely important thank you very much
and stay safe and stay healthy tell me
how it's going
we keep in touch wonderful thank you
you